Alabama Senate candidate Roy Moore
claims he is being harassed over
accusations that he pursued teenage
girls when he was in his 30s speaking at
a Christian revival meeting Moore said
that the stories of five women are a
political ploy he said Democrats and
Republicans are teaming up to keep him
out of Washington earlier the Republican
National Committee cut all fundraising
ties to the former judge Manuel
Bojorquez is in Jackson Alabama where
Moore spoke last night
Manuel good morning good morning if last
night's reception here was any
indication supporters are sticking by
their candidate despite growing anti-war
sentiment in Washington Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell said he spoke
with vice president Pence on Monday and
president Trump last Friday trying to
figure out how the GOP should deal with
Moore's candidacy a defiant Moore showed
no signs of bowing out while addressing
the support of crowd at the god save
America revival conference news host
Sean Hannity
who originally questioned the five women
accusing Moore of sexual misconduct
distance himself from the candidate last
night for me
the judge has 24 hours you must
immediately and fully come up with a
satisfactory explanations for your
inconsistencies if you can't do this
then judge Moore needs to get out of
this race
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
did not rule out trying to expel more if
the Alabama Republican wins he's
obviously not fit to be in the United
States Senate and we've looked at all
the options to try to prevent that from
happening in his testimony before the
House Judiciary Committee Attorney
General jeff sessions cited against the
man who wants his old Senate seat sir do
you believe these young women I am have
no reason to doubt these young women the
Democrat in the Alabama race Doug Jones
is capitalizing on the allegations in a
new TV ad you read the story in it
shakez you I'm a lifelong Republican but
I just can't do it
don't decency and integrity matter
anymore meanwhile there appear to be
attempts to discredit the allegations
against more a robo call from someone
claiming to be a Washington Post
reporter was received by an Alabama
pastor and played for our affiliate wkr
G address email between the ages of 54
to 57 years old really make damaging
reminds about Canada anymore
for a war between 5,000 and 7,000
dollars in a statement The Washington
Post which first published the
allegations said that call was fake and
that the newspaper is appalled anyone
would stoop to that level to discredit
real journalism sources also tells CBS
News that Steve Bannon who helped more
get nominated is now deliberating
whether he should publicly disavow him
Charlie thanks Manuel